how do you schedule videos via youtube
this is a question that came in front of
my movement students rich who's running
the inspired movement he has a company
called you gotta love and he creates
some amazing videos on YouTube and was
asking about how do i schedule these out
so i'm going to show it's pretty quick
so i'll just go to youtube so you go
upload now this is the important part
here okay usually you just drag a file
here or you click and you upload the key
thing you want to do so we can still do
that i can go find a file let me these
are some salsa pictures let's go find a
video I'm going to send the Christina
okay Nina at the fridge so when you're
here you can click on this and go
scheduled okay so instead of looking at
public I click scheduled and I could
pick whenever time I want so i can say
okay i want it to go you know june third
at seven pm the other great thing i like
about this is if you have integrated
your social media channels in here so
I've done it for Twitter and my Google+
not Facebook because this is your
personal Facebook there's no option at
least that I know up to share it to a
fan page so whenever this video goes
live it'll automatically send it to my
Twitter account and to my Google+ page
which is great so that's how you
schedule video and share with your
social media channels enjoy